there's so much to celebrate I'm sure
you're busy doing so many interviews
right now because we want to know how
you were feeling knowing that you're on
the cover and everyone knows about it
what does this moment feel like for you
well I this has been a dream come true
I've always hoped and wished and dreamt
on a star that this would happen and
yeah she'd be a reality for me is so
special and I could not be happier yeah
you put it on a vision board what four
years ago and you made this happen it's
almost like your dream came true here
you are on the cover what's next on your
vision board that's such a good question
it's so funny because I was talking to
my manager about this a few months ago I
was trying to get to think of my next
step and get stuck sometimes and you
lose the motivation it's the worst
feeling ever
but one of the things I really wanted to
start focusing on is getting more
involved with the charities that I
really care about maybe spearheading my
own drink something with female
empowerment but during 40 nights I had
the opportunity to create more than a
mask which is ask company your few of
our designs a mask company that it's all
profits go directly to feeding America
so this was strictly a passion project
for me and we're now and one mask sold
provides 100 meals to feeding America to
someone in need and I'm hoping we'll get
millions and millions of meals out there
so we're headed toward a million so if
anybody out there wants to purchase for
a great cause it's more than a massive
that Express and they're really cute
I've one hand because my puppies on my
lap but they're really nice I really
like those yeah you know and it's so
great to give back to you have this
you're just more grateful for everything
that you have in your life and the
priorities in your life change
especially at a time like this and you
giving back what has what has happened
for you that now you realize this is the
most important thing in my life I just
think that in general I felt really
guilty I was feeling very guilty because
I felt like so much of the world is
suffering and y'all know so much so many
are suffering all the time but you get
to get to a point where you have to do
something any
anything it's even just this tiniest
thing to just not only make yourself
feel better but know that you're
brightening someone's day making
someone's day better feeding them or
providing an opportunity whatever you
can listening learning we've all learned
so much about what we can do to become
better and I think that it means so much
to the community to other people but
also like to yourself I just say yeah
it's so rewarding to be able to have
especially this company for me it's been
so rewarding I'm just you know what's
rewarding is to see you Jasmin and Kate
on the cover together showing diversity
and how this magazine has evolved over
the years and showing body positivity I
mean for you to be part of it in 2020 is
so meaningful so what does it mean for
you to be part of a magazine that is
acknowledging change it's so I'm so
honored to be a part of magazine every
year they come out with things there
that I really they just make you think
last year there was a man European
Brenna Huck's this year's there's
Valentino the first trio they are always
paving the way they're always
trailblazing and breaking down
boundaries and creating conversations
and it's so beautiful because we all
know there's so much more to these women
than the picture you see and it's
nothing orient about their inspiration
what they'll go on to do and it's always
stood for that but more more than ever
they are continuing down that path now
yeah so how did you celebrate who did
you celebrate with how did it did you
have a moment to celebrate oh my gosh
well I was on vacation in the middle of
an island with absolutely no suit
service and they had to tell me and they
were trying to think of a way that they
could actually sit me down during I had
five day vacation and I'm getting
bothered I was so annoyed but they told
me Olivia you have an interview with
vogue it's very important it's gonna go
to Anna you got to do it I was like oh
my okay I gotta do this so you're like
they want Christian in it also so I had
to get Christian to come and sit down in
the interview with me but he he like
didn't want to do it knew the whole time
he was like he knew it the whole time he
was like Olivia I'm not doing that
interview no vacation I hate
skills baryon brand freeze anything of
it and then we sat down and they started
with the couples in the tape talk couple
challenge so they were like I yeah like
who's the better dancer he is whose
mother cooked me who's on the cover so
straight that was like and I just
started crying it was really that's how
you found out yeah yeah so beautiful so
have you had a chance to text I mean you
guys would be on tour right now doing
media traveling the world so have you
had a chance to text
Jasmin and Kate and kind of celebrate
together and have this discussion of
being on the cover together oh yeah we
text all the time Jasmine's coming over
tonight actually she's for a tequila
shot so Jasmine she's actually my
neighbor and then Kate is in New York
but we talk all the time yeah and
they're great I we love each other you
know I was looking back at one of my
favorite post of you was from last year
on me eight I think it was and it was
you in Australia and you're beautiful
Sports Illustrated shot you're just just
glowing and you talk about the idea of
being grateful and what's in your life
in those blessings and there's so much
truth to that so what is your what are
you most grateful for right now I think
first and foremost health and the health
with my family and my friends first I
think that more than ever I mean just
being away even from my mom and dad like
I miss them so much I could it's like
makes me emotional thinking about it
because I really it's it's hard being
apart but it's also you you realize how
scary life can be and how unexpected it
can be and things can change in a minute
obviously but more so now than ever I
think I've realized how fragile life is
and how much you have to be grateful for
so I mean yeah that's my numero uno
what are you looking forward to after
isolation but one thing you want to do I
I want to go back to Rhode Island really
badly and see my family I want to go I
want my friends to come over without a
mask I really really want that
just hugging people right like they just
miss that so much people and I don't
want people to be I don't want people to
be living in here but we have to be you
have to be responsible that's the right
thing to do but it would be nice when we
don't have to live in such fear yeah you
know you are the epitome of
understanding that dreams can come true
so for the girls who are watching right
now or just you know just going through
this period of understanding this
pandemic what's your advice to them
about going forward I would say I hope
that I can be a testament to the fact
that dreams can come true persistence if
everything that I wrote on my Instagram
posts today about the Sports Illustrated
cover is true I I was shooting for the
stars and it was unfathomable to me and
it was something that I just kept in the
back of my head and no one would have
ever thought at that time it would be
possible but that's just something that
happens whenever you're trying to
achieve a goal that's not tangible you
know one will believe it but you have to
hold on to it and I know that sounds
kind of hokey and I guess I am kind of
sappy but I love that not I believe you
have to hold on to it it can be your own
little secret no one will understand yes
huh
tangible but you have to hold on to it
that can be hard sometimes what do you
see when you see that yourself on the
magazine cover I haven't seen that I
haven't physically held it it really hit
me I have to be honest with you
hey and still it doesn't feel real it
doesn't feel real how do you define
beauty I think beauty is shown in the
way you treat others and I think the way
you treat others is a reflection of how
you feel inside so ultimately it boils
down to self love thank you so much
congratulations on the cover we're so
excited for you
and say hi to your little puppy well
he's asleep when he wakes up take care
thanks everybody